(En el siglo V antes de Cristo, durante
la invasión de Termópilas, 300 soldados
espartanos aguantaron estoicamente durante
días el ataque de unos 200.000 soldados persas.
Hoy, 2.500 años después, podemos encontrar
un pequeño país con la misma filosofía de
resistencia, determinación y movilización popular.
Y no, por sorprendente que parezca
no estamos hablando de Israel.)
Queridos amigos, amigas, ¿Tenéis alguna idea de
qué pequeño país podemos estar hablando? 3,2,1…
Vale, sí, lo sé, el factor
sorpresa no es nuestro fuerte,
porque la respuesta está en el propio título
de este vídeo, pero había que darle emoción.
Así que sí, habéis acertado: en este
vídeo vamos a hablar de Singapur.
Y no de cualquier Singapur, sino del Singapur más
desconocido, más castrense, intimidante y fuerte.
Casi, casi, de la mismísima Esparta del Siglo XXI.
Así que sin más preámbulo… ¡Arranquemos!
Singapur es un país pequeño, muy
pequeño, prácticamente diminuto.
Sin embargo, a pesar de tener menos de 6 millones
de habitantes y apenas 730 kilómetros cuadrados,
una extensión similar a la de la
ciudad de Nueva York y la mitad que
otras como Londres o la Ciudad de México,
Singapur es toda una potencia militar.
Sí, sí, lo habéis escuchado bien. Hablamos
de una potencia militar de primer orden
que por sí misma sería capaz de hacer
frente a casi cualquier país del mundo.
Porque amigos, Singapur tiene una de las
fuerzas armadas mejor dotadas de todo el mundo.
(Las fuerzas armadas de Singapur cuentan con algo
más de 70.000 efectivos profesionales a
tiempo completo, unos 400.000 efectivos
a tiempo parcial y más de 1,2 millones
de reservistas con formación militar.
Porque sí, en Singapur existe un
servicio militar obligatorio para
todos los hombres de dos años
de duración. Es el llamado NS.
De esta forma, las fuerzas armadas regulares,
ya sea a tiempo completo o parcial,
suponen el 8% de toda la población del país. Al
tiempo que la población entrenada militarmente
y disponible representa casi una cuarta parte
de todos los habitantes de esta ciudad-estado.
Y eso no es todo. Iincluso, desde el año
2015 este país también cuenta con un ejército
de voluntarios, el conocido como Cuerpo de
Voluntarios de las Fuerzas Armadas de Singapur,
que también está abierto a las mujeres y cuya
edad de pertenencia se eleva hasta los 45 años.)
Probablemente en ningún otro país del mundo
la población esté tan involucrada en las
fuerzas armadas. Pero, estad tranquilos,
porque no hemos hecho más que empezar.
Como todos seguramente ya sabéis,
en la guerra moderna, la cantidad
de soldados disponibles no es el elemento
más importante para lograr una victoria.
Por encima del número de efectivos está la
tecnología disponible y el equipamiento militar.
Algo en lo que Singapur, uno de
los países más ricos del mundo,
tampoco ha escatimado durante las últimas décadas.
(Por ejemplo, Singapur tiene más
aviones de combate que las fuerzas
aéreas de países como Canadá, Suecia
o Países Bajos. En capacidad están
incluso por encima de las fuerzas aéreas de
países como España. Y es que, hablamos de
equipos avanzados adquiridos a la industria
militar de Estados Unidos, Israel y Europa.
De hecho, Singapur ha sido el primer país de todo
el Sudeste Asiático en hacerse con
el caza de quinta generación F-35.)
Evidentemente, tal y como os podéis imaginar,
el presupuesto militar de esté país no es
precisamente pequeño, sobre todo si tenemos
en cuenta que se trata de una ciudad-estado
con menos de 6 millones de habitantes.
Pues bien, en 2021 el gasto militar de esta
ciudad superó los 11.500 millones de dólares,
lo que supone casi el triple que el presupuesto
militar de su vecino Malasia y un 25% más que el
gasto militar de Indonesia, un país
que tiene 46 veces más habitantes.
Para que os hagáis una idea,
hablamos de un presupuesto similar al
de un lugar tan amenazado como Taiwán.
¿No os resulta sorprendente?
Singapur es un territorio muy rico y con mucha
seguridad jurídica. Uno de los enclaves dónde
van a parar los capitales de millones de
inversores y empresas de todo el mundo.
Un estatus que necesita protección. Y con los
datos en la mano parece que lo
tienen muy pero que muy claro.
El caso es que desde que lograra
su independencia en 1965,
este pequeño país asiático ha tenido
tres grandes estrategias militares.
Tres grandes estrategias militares que explican
su percepción del mundo y que con el paso de
los años han dado forma a sus relativamente
enormes y bien equipadas fuerzas armadas.
Porque amigos, amigas, nada de lo
que os hemos contado es casual.
Atentos.
(LA GAMBAENVENENADA)
La primera estrategia militar, la gran
estrategia de defensa de Singapur,
llegó poco después de su independencia
de la mano del célebre Lee Kuan Yew,
El histórico Primer Primer Ministro que diseñó
el actual Singapur y que gobernó durante 20 años.
El caso es que tras separarse del Reino Unido,
integrarse en Malasia y ser expulsado en apenas
2 años,Lee Kuan Yew tuvo muy claro que para poder
sobrevivir Singapur tenía que convertirse
en un lugar que nadie quisiera invadir.
Una idea que plasmó en 1966 de forma muy
clara en una de sus citas más conocidas.
(En un mundo en el que el pez grande se
come al pequeño, y el pequeño come gambas,
Singapur debe convertirse en una gama
envenenada. [...] Si te las comes,
tendrás problemas digestivos.” - Lee Kuan Yew)
Cuando Lee Kuan Yew pronunció estas palabras
la situación de Singapur era radicalmente
distinta a su status actual. En aquel momento
Singapur era un país pobre, sin apenas aliados,
rodeado de vecinos algo hostiles y que tenía
que sobrevivir en un mundo partido en dos.
Singapur tenía que ser capaz de defenderse
por sí mismo. El objetivo era que invadir
este enclave se volviera una operación
tan costosa en términos de dinero,
vida y recursos militares que ningún otro
país tuviera la tentación de hacerlo.
La defensa de Singapur tenía que ser capaz de
infligir el mayor daño posible al enemigo incluso
si este lograba invadir la ciudad. Si eso ocurría
Singapur se convertiría en la gamba envenenada.
[Una estrategia, por cierto, muy
similar a la que muchos analistas
defienden que tiene que adoptar
Taiwán para defenderse de China.
Ahora bien, la pregunta es, ¿Cómo
lograr todo esto en la práctica?
¿Cómo conseguir convertirse en
toda una “gamba envenenada”?
Pues bien, fundamentalmente mediante
tres vías: armándose hasta los dientes,
preparándose para el combate
y consiguiendo amigos fuertes.
(Cuando Singapur se independizó, la ciudad-estado
apenas contaba con dos batallones de
infantería, un viejo cañón y ningún
avión de combate. Había que construir
un ejército prácticamente desde cero.
Para lograrlo, Lee Kuan Yew le dio a su
Ministro de Interior y Defensa, Goh Keng
Swee, una orden secreta: Singapur tenía que
estrechar lazos con Israel, Egipto y la India.)
¿Y sabéis qué? De los tres la respuesta
más efusiva llegó precisamente de Israel,
un país desesperado por lograr
“amigos” en el exterior.
Así que Israel no solo fue uno de los
primeros estados en reconocer a Singapur,
sino que en octubre de 1965, apenas 2 meses
después de proclamar su plena independencia, el
ejército hebreo ya estaba manos a la obra ayudando
a diseñar las fuerzas armadas de este nuevo país.
Claro que la cosa no era tan sencilla.
La colaboración entre estos dos países
tenía que ser lo más discreta posible.
Tan discreta que nadie podía enterarse.
¿Por qué? Pues… Pensad un momento en los
dos países que rodean a la ciudad-estado:
Malasia e Indonesia. Dos grandes países
musulmanes que en aquella época, como
prácticamente todos los países musulmanes,
tenían a Israel en el punto de mira.
Así que si Singapur no quería ser visto como un
elemento hostil y correr el riesgo de justificar
una invasión tenía que tirar de inventiva. Fijaos.
(Los primeros asesores militares enviados
de Israel a Singapur fueron llamados
“mexicanos” por discreción - Mothership)
Y, ojo, porque para hacerlo creíble,
Israel seleccionó para la operación
a miembros de sus fuerzas armadas cuyos
rasgos les permitiera hacerse pasar por
mexicanos. Así que nada de soldados y oficiales
rubios o con la piel excesivamente blanca.
Y, ojo, que esta anécdota la cuenta el propio
Lee Kuan Yew en sus memorias publicadas en 1998.
El caso es que de esta colaboración salió
el llamado “Libro Marrón”, un plan maestro
capitaneado por el entonces subdirector de
operaciones de las FDI israelíes Rehavam Ze'evi.
(“Quiero que recordéis varias cosas.
Uno, no vamos a convertir a Singapur
en una colonia israelí. Vuestra tarea
es enseñarles la profesión militar,
ponerlos de pie para que puedan dirigir su
propio ejército. [...] En segundo lugar,
no vais allí para dirigirlos,
sino para aconsejarlos. Y tercero,
no sois comerciantes de armas. Cuando recomendéis
equipamiento para adquirir, utilizad el más puro
criterio militar profesional." - Yitzhak Rabin,
antiguo Ramatcal y Primer Ministro de Israel)
De esta forma, en apenas tres meses, los
israelíes crearon toda una estrategia
y doctrina militar cuyo eje central era
construir un ejército ciudadano de reclutas,
que fueran entrenados y dirigidos por una pequeña
fuerza regular muy profesional y bien equipada.
¿Os recuerda a algo esta estructura? Exacto,
es exactamente el mismo modelo
que continúa en vigor hoy en día.
Pero bien, el caso es que para lograr
este objetivo y conseguir que el país
tuviera doce batallones listos para
defender la ciudad en menos de una
década fue por lo que se estableció
el servicio militar obligatorio.
La idea, básicamente, era lograr que toda
la nación pudiera movilizarse en caso de ser
necesario. Y que esa enorme capacidad fuera
el gran bastión de la defensa de la ciudad.
Pero claro, a medida que el país se fue
enriqueciendo y las fuerzas armadas lograron estar
más equipadas y mejor entrenadas, se hizo evidente
que hacía falta actualizar la estrategia militar.
Pues bien, ese momento llegó con la década
de los 80. A partir de ese momento, la visión
militar de Singapur evolucionó hasta querer
convertirse en toda una gran potencia militar.
Atentos.
(PUERCOESPINES Y DELFINES: SINGAPUR YA ESTÁ AQUÍ)
Década y media.
Ese fue todo el tiempo que le llevó a
Singapur pasar de ser de una empobrecida
colonia de pescadores sin ejército, a estar
en condiciones de actuar militarmente fuera
de sus propios límites territoriales.
Y en esto se basó, precisamente,
la segunda estrategia militar singapurense, la
conocida como la estrategia del puercoespín,
que empezó a aplicarse a principios de
los 80 y que supuso un enorme cambio.
Singapur ya no tenía la necesidad de asumir, de
aceptar que podía terminar siendo invadido, aunque
fuera a un alto coste, que era, básicamente, lo
que planteaba la idea de la gamba envenenada.
Ahora ya tenían la formación y el equipamiento
suficiente para convertir su modelo de
defensa pasiva en otro mucho más activo. Esta
doctrina estuvo en vigor hasta la llegada del
nuevo siglo y supuso el paso necesario para
terminar de construir un ejército moderno.
(Siguiendo la doctrina del puercoespín Singapur
no solo se convirtió en un importante cliente de
la industria militar norteamericana, israelí
y europea - lo que ya de por si le daba una
enorme influencia - sino que también desarrolló
su propia industria local de equipos militares.
Una industria que le ha permitido a
Singapur convertirse en uno de los
30 mayores exportadores de armas por volumen
de todo el mundo. Entre sus equipos con más
éxito podemos destacar el rifle de asalto
SAR21, el todoterreno militar BRONCO o el
blindado de transporte TERREX, así como un
montón de drones y obuses de todo tipo.)
Pero aquí no termina todo. Actualmente
Singapur aplica su tercera gran estrategia,
la conocida como doctrina del delfín.
[Gamba, puercoespín y delfín.
Esto va de animales.]
Pero, ¿por qué el delfín?
Pues veréis, el delfín es un animal tremendamente
ágil que es capaz de utilizar esta agilidad
incluso para atacar a tiburones, a
pesar de no ser tan fuerte como ellos.
Y esa es precisamente la idea.
Bajo esta doctrina, Singapur está construyendo una
fuerza impresionante aérea, muy fuerte y muy ágil,
capaz de anticiparse a cualquier
amenaza. Es decir, lograr la total
superioridad aérea en la región.
Para lograr este enorme poder de
respuesta y anticipación, el actual primer
ministro Lee Hsien Loong ha puesto en marcha
un ambicioso plan para adaptar toda la
estructura militar a esta nueva misión.
(Entre las claves de la nueva estrategia, está
la sustitución de la antigua flota de F-16
por los F-35B de quinta generación así como la
renovación y ampliación de la flota de su Armada
que actualmente opera seis fragatas multimisión
basadas en la clase La Fayette francesa.
También destaca la adquisición de
armas clave como los tanques Leopard
de segunda generación alemanes, los
vehículos autóctonos de combate Hunter,
en servicio desde 2019, o el lanzamisiles
estadounidense Lockheed Martin M142 HIMARS,
de los que Singapur cuenta ya
con dos docenas de equipos.)
De esta forma es como Singapur se convirtió
primero en una ciudad militarizada,
luego en una fortaleza inexpugnable y ahora
en un actor militar capaz de aplicar aquella
máxima que dice que llegado el caso “la
mejor defensa puede ser un buen ataque”.
Pero, un momento, porque no
todo pasa por el arsenal.
Singapur lleva muchos años potenciando
las sinergias militares con sus aliados,
en especial a través del entrenamiento militar.
Actualmente los soldados de Singapur
se entrenan en países tan dispares
como Estados Unidos, Australia,
Tailandia, Taiwán o Sudáfrica,
y frecuentemente participan en ejercicios
militares defensivos a gran escala.
Además, Singapur también ha sellado
importantes acuerdos de defensa con el Tío Sam,
acuerdos que incluyen el acceso a bases militares
singapurenses de los soldados norteamericanos..
(Singapur renueva el pacto de bases
militares con Estados Unidos en mitad
de la profundización de los lazos
de defensa frente a China- SCMP
Washington renueva el acuerdo
garantizando el acceso de las
fuerzas norteamericanas a las bases
de la Ciudad del León hasta 2035,
subrayando la importancia de la ciudad para
la estrategia de Estados Unidos en Asia)
(Armadas de 21 países inician ejercicios
liderados por Estados Unidos en
el sudeste asiático - AL Jazeera
Los ejercicios SEACAT están en marcha en
Singapur al tiempo que virtualmente Pekín
y Moscú también llevan a cabo
ejercicios en Ningxia, China)
Claro que un momento, esto no quiere decir
que Singapur sea un actor beligerante,
pasa nada. Una cosa es llevarse bien con Estados
Unidos y otra muy distinta llevarse mal con China.
Y aquí Singapur juega, digamos, con una
cierta ventaja: el 69% de los chinos tiene
una buena imagen de esta ciudad-estado,
cuyo modelo el mismísimo Deng Xiaoping
tomó como ejemplo para poner en marcha las
reformas que han construido la China de Hoy.
Singapur es algo así como la combinación entre la
vocación militar de Esparta y
la histórica neutralidad suiza.
Esta, querida comunidad de VisualPolitik,
es una gran plaza financiera, un refugio para
capitales y negocios de todo el mundo. Para
ello tanto la fuerza como la vocación
de neutralidad juegan un papel clave.
Sea como sea, esta es la cara
menos conocida de Singapur. Su
rol como toda una potencia militar
a pesar de tener menos de 6 millones
de habitantes y menos de la mitad de
superficie que la ciudad de Londres.
Ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitik si aún no lo habéis hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.